So you would be 25% related to a grandparent, an aunt
or uncle, and a half sibling. Now what's the reason behind
this? Well let's start with the grandparent. You're 50% related to
each of your own parents. And that means each of your parents
are 50% related to each of their parents. And 50% of
50% in this case would be 25%. So you're 25% related
to a parent of your parent. Or your grandparent. Now, in
the case of your aunt and uncle, there's something similar going on.
The full sibling of your parent is related to them
50%, so this means your aunt are related to your
parents 50%. So, if you're 50% related to your parent,
and they're 50% related to your parent, that's 50% and
50%. You're 25%, again, in this case. But the half-sibling
option is a little bit trickier. Of course, you share
50% with each of your parents, and your half-sibling also
shares 50% with each of their parents, and you share
that parent. The trick is, the same 50% that
they give you is not the same 50% that they
gave your half-sibling. And the reason is because of
recombination during meiosis. We learned about this in lesson five.
Remember that when meiosis happens and the sex cells
are created, they must figure out how they're going to pass
on half the genome. And every time they do this,
they mix and match the chromosomes slightly differently. So that
in the end, a half sibling shares 25% with you instead of a full 50%.